eric diard bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale rt france alors on l'a vu à
l'instant le chef de l'état s'est donc
emparé d'un sujet cher à la droite celui
de la sécurité
en déplacement hier à montpellier sur ce
thème là dit vouloir plus de bleu dans
le pays dix mille policiers et gendarmes
annoncé donc d'ici 2022
est ce que c'est un bon cap selon vous
comment est ce que vous avez perçu
finalement cette annonce du chef de
l'état c'est évidemment on peut que s'en
réjouir mais ces annonces sont un peu
tardives on s'en trouve bien république
tu es rétif kotama son mini d'intérieur
devant d'ailleurs sur les questions de
sécurité de même sur les questions de
laïcité de séparatisme la loi a été
longue à coucher certains points il ya
des angles morts dont sept lois n'ont
pas été abordées à la demande du
plaignant et public donc c'est une bonne
chose mais en 5 qu'il faut un petit peu
le cul c'est pour aborder les faits
alors qu'il ya le sujet de la mixité
aussi qui s'est invité hier lors de ce
déplacement mme a vu cette femme
cette femme voilée qui s'adressait au
chef de l'état et elles s'inquiétaient
de la disparition des prénoms français
dont son quartier regarder je déplore un
manque de mixité dans le collège du
quartier les gens ne mettent plus les
enfants dans le même quartier ce qui est
vraiment dommage
monsieur le président j'ai mon fils qui
habite ans il m'a demandé si le prénom
de pierre existait vraiment ou si ce
n'était que dans les livres
tellement il ya un manque de mixité dans
le quartier c'est vraiment grave
alors comment est ce que vous avez perçu
cet épisode qu'est-ce qui ils révèlent
selon vous mais alors que un constat
d'échec même constat d'échec e groupe
est à dire de notre république
je vais paraphraser un livre les
territoires perdus la république en avec
les territoires et donc pour recréer une
maxime mixité dans ces territoires
cela devient difficile mais c'est pas la
mixité qu'il faut d'abord vivait il faut
donner à ces territoires et services
publics
des développements économiques pour que
les personnes ne les abandonnent plus et
votre famille politique elle a sa
responsabilité aussi pour vous mettrez
pas toutes les familles politiques en
leur actualité
sauf que quand même notre famille
politique avait sorti quand même un plan
le plan borloo pour la réhabilitation
des quartiers qui a eu évidemment
quelques défauts mais quand vous écoutez
les personnes des médiateurs des
quartiers ils reconnaissent que seul ce
plan a créé quand même une véritable
dynamique sur ces 30 dernières années
en tout cas ça marche pas vraiment on
constate pourquoi pourquoi ça marche pas
parce que premièrement le plan borloo
n'existe plus monsieur maquereau a
souhaité les rushs de l'heureux je le
reprends et puis vous allez lui il a
abandonné lancé munich en rase campagne
donc j'ai difficile les frais quartier
le problème
il ya aussi quand même n'oublions pas la
part du religieux qui a gagné ses
quartiers nous ne nous avons oublié le
principe fondamental de notre république
et la laïcité la liberté de croire ou ne
pas croire et la part du religieux à
prix du terrain sur ses quartiers et
donc les personnes qui ne se sentent pas
concernés par la religion en créer et
qui se sentent en insécurité n'était pas
liée à la religion contenait aussi des
différents trafics a abandonné ses
quartiers et même des musulmans qu'ils
voulaient une autre vie pour leurs
enfants abandonnés ces quartiers quand
il le pouvait la question dalli cité on
vend par les ajustements dans quelques
instants
peut-être un mot sur ces policiers en
colère en colère contre la justice
notamment après ce verdict 1 ce week-end
dans la sphère de viry châtillon où des
policiers ont été brûlés huit accusés
ont été relaxés et des syndicats je le
disais sont en colère regarder le ce
tweet d'alliance police procès en appel
de viry-châtillon encore un signal
d'encouragement envoyées aux racailles
qui après avoir brûlé vif des policiers
leur crache à la figure au tribunal
comment est-ce que vous l'entendez ce
sera le bol des policiers est ce que la
justice allait effectivement trop
laxistes
je vais pas dire ça comment on a pu
arriver à ce que ces personnes soient
relâchés acquittés faute de preuves je
pose la question est ce que la justice
est laxiste est ce que la réussite d'un
pas eu suffisamment d'éléments mais je
comprends les policiers qui se sentent
pas dire complètement lâché c'est un
beau défi donner à la police est un bon
film donné d'aller dire aux voyous a
fait criminel envie d'envoyer vous
pourrez essayer de trouver des idées des
policiers et [ __ ] ait échappé à la prison
il ya un autre verdict qui a choqué
aussi ces dernières heures c'est celui
de l' affaire halimi 1 tout en
confirmant le caractère antisémite du
crime la justice a estimé que l'auteur
sous l'emprise de cannabis était
irresponsable
regardez cette réaction du porte-parole
du gouvernement si vous commettez un
crime odieux après avoir pris des
stupéfiants et qu'après on vous dit que
parce que vous avez pris des stupéfiants
vous ne serez pas jugés
c'est totalement inacceptable pour les
français est-ce que c'est effectivement
nécessaire pour vous de revoir cette
question d'abolition du discernement ou
alors au contraire c'est une décision de
justice et il faut la respecter
non il faut revoir parce que dans ce cas
là il s'agit pas d'une personne qui est
dans un état d'euphorie cet état de
folie qui et j'allais dire partager
donc vous pouvez pas ma un moment de la
drogue de l'alcool des médicaments et
dire voilà je n'étais pas dans mon état
normal et ensuite vous retrouver un état
normal
pour moi l'état de la personne qui n'est
pas responsable c'est une personne qui a
un qui a un état qui est permanent et
que après les actes elle n'est pas
consciente de ses actes voilà il faut
quand même à pouvoir légiférer
c'est trop facile de s'abriter derrière
un état de folie passagers alors vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure la question de
la laïcité justement le gouvernement
lance aujourd'hui des états généraux de
la laïcité on le rappelle alors que le
projet doit séparatisme
être durcies au sénat alors ces états
généraux ils vont associer des religieux
des intellectuels des associations des
syndicats des jeunes français est ce
qu'une telle compte que concertation est
ce qu'elle est nécessaire mais elle
aurait dû se faire avant la loi
vous l'avez dit c'est à dire normalement
fait des états généraux et a planté une
loi la loi a été discuté à la fin mai a
discuté au sénat et en belle isle états
généraux à l'issue de cette loi alors
bon c'est une décision ne marchera pas
j'espère fait pas simplement une
opération de com bon souhaitons qu on
puisse s'expliquer grâce à tous ces
intellectuels ses invités ce qu'est la
laïcité et la laïcité c'est un principe
de la laïcité voulons retrouver
l'article 1 de la constitution et un
procès un principe en droit français ce
n'est pas négociable
ce n'est pas discutable la laïcité n'est
pas à géométrie variable
il faut expliquer et la loi devient 5e
div et dans son article 1 que la laïcité
c'est la liberté de conscience la
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire et
c'est la république qui l'assurent et
tuent par conséquent on ne peut pas
discuter et les incursions ligne
l'immixtion du religieux doit être
stoppée elle dans la sphère publique
regardez l'objectif asie c'est en tout
cas de marennes chappard sur ces états
généraux
la laïcité n'est en aucun cas une arme
de répression contre les religions nous
voulons justement sortir de la tenaille
entre d'un côté les identitaires
d'extrême droite et de l'autre les
indigéniste et europe ecologie les verts
alors yannick jadot d'europe écologie
les verts pas très contents a répondu
que le gouvernement était sur le
juste de la propagande regarder les
insultes de marlène schiappa doivent
cesser j'appelle le président et le
premier ministre à remettre les
institutions en ordre on ne fait pas un
débat après une loi et débattre ce n'est
pas fabriqué un outil de propagande
alors est ce que c'est un outil de
propagande selon vous ces états généraux
de la laïcité comme le souligne yannick
jadot
déjà je comprends pas pourquoi ensuite
europe ecologie les verts premier mandat
europe ecologie les verts il ya antoine
et peu de tout mais en dessous des
personnes comme yannick jadot
ils sont quand même très attachée au
principe de laïcité
alors c'est vrai c'est peut-être une
opération comme comme j'ai dû accroît
quatre jours madame chapa qui voulaient
des quartiers où on interdit d dragueur
lourd contre au niveau des harcèlements
de route j'ai toujours pas compris qu'on
allait faire ça donc j'ai il faut vous
dire quand même madame cher pas que la
politique ce n'est pas un brainstorming
permanente et pas de se lever le matin
d'hier on a une idée bon ça va se faire
souhaitons qu on arrive à expliquer aux
jeunes qu'est la laïcité que la licité
des pas contre la religion musulmane
puisque la loi
vous imaginez c'est là une loi de
décembre 1905
à cette époque là la religion musulmane
était cali que les biens kg absente de
notre pays
du moins en métropole donc à partir de
là il faut arriver à faire un débat
apaisé mais ça peut faire l'effet
contraire il faut être prudent
alors il ya un autre sujet de tension
notamment à droite ces dernières heures
ce sont les mots d' emmanuel macron au
cours d'un entretien avec le média
américain cbs le chef de l'état est
revenu sur la question de la race et sur
le passé colonial de la france
on écoute ma conviction est que nous
devons aborder cette question en
commençant par la transparence et une
évaluation équitable
c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé deux nouvelles
plateformes pour lutter contre la
discrimination le racisme et cetera
deuxièmement un dialogue calme est
ouvert pour comprendre comment cela
s'est passé est d'une certaine manière
pour déconstruire notre propre histoire
dé construire notre propre histoire
comment est ce que vous vous prenez ces
maudits chef de l'état moi je comprends
par ne déconstruit pas en analyse n'en
peux pas dé construire l'histoire cette
histoire s'est passé on sait très bien
que
colonisation des côtés positifs et des
côtés négatifs
il faut en discuter mais pour être aidé
pour discuter il faut être deux c'est à
dire quand la france tend la main en
algérie avec le rapport stores a fait
des propositions de l'autre côté aucun
rapport que l'algérie attend que la
faute de la france simplement de la
repentance
non quand on veut faire un débat quand
on veut discuter il faut être deux et
pour l'instant c'est simplement un seul
côté c'est la france qui veut drôle il a
beau le nier le président est toujours
dans la repentance et il faut arrêter
parce que maintenant il faut regarder
devant
tout en discutant de notre passé et en
reconnaissant qu'il ya eu des abus mais
les abus de côté comme de l'autre la
guerre d'algérie c'est une guerre avec
des massacres de le côté comme de
l'autre il faut que l'admettre il faut
que l'algérie aussi admettre les
massacres quand été fait pendant des
semaines
alors il nous reste quelques minutes on
va peut-être on est à aborder la
question de votre famille politique on
est à un peu plus d'un an des élections
présidentielles on a beaucoup parlé de
l'union de la gauche elle la droite elle
aussi se cherche un candidat voyez ce
qu'on a dit rachida dati
une fois la pandémie maîtriser le temps
viendra pour la désignation d'un
candidat unique de la droite et du
centre
et je sors un artisan de notre victoire
en 2022
alors rien d'aisé xavier bertrand qui
est candidat pour la droite
est ce que vous le soutenez ou alors est
ce que comme rachida dati et bien vous
attendez une autre candidature à
l'automne par exemple rachida dati qui
n'attendent pas une autre candidature
simplement elle elle souhaite apporter
sa part j'allais dire à la droite et je
pense que moi je soutiens clairement aux
adhérents et je pense que rachida dati
veut dire que à partir après l'académie
1 1 un candidat devrait ou une candidate
devrait se détacher elle n'a pas parlé
vous avez entendu de primaire et ses
sept candidats ou ce candidat qui a
remporté plus tôt l'adhésion des
français et le devons tous partir
derrière lui derrière elle avant avant
de nous quitter peut-être une heure de
questions sur la situation sanitaire
est-ce que vous pensez que les
restaurants que les restrictions vont
pouvoir être allégée rapidement début
même lit mais qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
il le faut il le faut c'est plus tenable
il ya borné sur un bateau s'est pas
encore je pense qu'on a un petit
décalage
le président a eu raison de prendre les
mesures pour pas peut-être que c'est
facile après coup il fallait les prendre
plus tôt pour les vacances de février on
serait dans la situation
comme d'autres pays comme comme
l'angleterre comme la suisse etc
il faut je souhaite vraiment que le 15
mai on puisse ouvrir les restaurants les
bars les terrasses enfin tout ce qui a
erré il le faut parce que c'est voilà
une somme qualifiée économique
ça devient très difficile il y en a qui
ont des aides c'est sûr mais adana dot
qui ont eu ou calais ouvert peu de temps
avant la pas baby et qui ne bénéficient
pas dead
ils sont en train de mourir nous aurons
quand même je ne sais pas dit-elle % des
établissements qui vendent plus rouvrir
suite à cette pandémie est donc
maintenant cela devient urgent
d'envisager au plus rapidement que le
plus rapidement possible la réouverture
merci beaucoup eric diard d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans la matinale
de rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
député les liens des bouches du rhône